joining me here for the first time it's
good to have you right here on the show
sir the new show on fox Thursdays at
9:00 Eastern Time started debuting last
week episode 2 is coming up on Thursday
night 9:00 Eastern Time the man who
plays deputy in deputy none other than
Stephen Dorff good to see you sir thank
you buddy thanks for having thanks for
being here yeah by the way your voice is
and gravelly and ready to roll right
it's just ready to roll over Josh and
show by the way we need do that one more
time can I do that here we go seventh
door four three two one ready to roll on
the Rich Eisen show Wow so so you're
born and raised in Atlanta were born in
Atlanta we're in Atlanta cuz my dad went
to college at University of Georgia so
okay yeah I still kind of have a bulldog
thing in loins in my family because my
dad still good buddies with vince dooley
who was the old head coach yeah and
funny enough when we were shooting this
pilot we shot half of it in Atlanta and
I was at dinner at the Chop House which
was the steak house right near the hotel
I've been there and vince dooley was
there and i hadn't seen him since I was
a little kid so I went up to him and he
immediately you know knew me and his
wife was really friendly and we talked
we called my dad together and it was
he's a really nice man cuz I went when
Herschel Walker was on that team back
when I was like 12 or 18 I went to a
Georgia game and sat on the sidelines
with them and because my dad we had a
really close relationship with him with
Vince so you're growing up and that's
uncle Vince did we call him oh you know
he's still a good friend of my dad's and
and I still like the I still root for
the Bulldogs here and they're very good
I'm trying to do the math would that be
ugga 3 ugga 4 I mean I was born there
and I moved to LA when I was about 4
months old so my dad was a songwriter
and when he finished college my parents
from New York but my mom was visiting my
dad's so they had me in Buckhead in
Atlanta and then we we moved to the San
Fernando Valley when I was 3 months old
right and my dad wrote some hit songs
and she's got any what's your dad rock
my dad's first big one was every which
way but loose from the Clint Eastwood
movie Oh Eddie Rabbitt yeah I was I was
six months old and and then your dad
wrote every which way yeah yeah so does
that mean did you go on the set of every
which way I didn't go on the set but I
love that that orangutan dad you know
but I could probably couldn't even talk
because I was maybe a year old
okay sure okay cuz my dad then did that
the Clint did like three of those he did
Bronco Billy than any which way you can
my dad did kind of all of Clint's movies
for that kind of four decades so Clint's
orangutan period or longer than that
orangutan period and then longer and
then but I always gave my dad crap
because I said dad you stop scoring
Clint's movies when he started making
really good movies like like Unforgiven
and had some amazing movies but now yeah
but Clint and my dad I think remain good
buddies and you know he's always I've
met him a few times just in my own
career yes auditioning for movies along
the way and he's always been really
sweet about my dad and nice to me that's
so cool so Stephen Dorff you're on the
Rich Eisen show is there any I guess
growing up in LA
any specific LA sports team that you I
mean I - I always loved the Dodgers and
I always you know and that was you know
I've always loved the Lakers - I've been
you know I'm a huge basketball fan I
love basketball and the Clippers are
pretty awesome - yeah they're weren't
wearing a a Golden Age potentially over
the next couple of years of Los Angeles
basketball the Lakers fans don't want to
ever ignominy that leaders could
possibly make anything better
as you in this town yeah I still have
love for the you know the purple and
yellow and in a way I think maybe just
because of all the years of being in LA
and going to those games and but you
must be talking about the form the old
form data form and then yeah into
staples but I probably went to more
games at the forum cuz since Showtime
now you're talking about Showtime Lakers
there ya talking about worthy and magic
and Pat Riley with a hair slicked back
and all that business oh yeah for sure I
think you know for me the for me the
I've just been gone working or I'd be in
more games this year you know I'd love
to I'm kind of every time I see my
friend at the Staples Center I'm like I
want to go to a game but I'm never here
right
so you gotta kind of be here Hey look it
when you're on a show like deputy and
you're your you got a you got to work
this is gotta work for a living you know
and it's well so before we dive a little
bit deeper into deputy true detective
what was that like to be on the third
season of that show that was that was
awesome I mean it was a you know I just
come from a kind of a not a great spot
in my personal life I'd lost my little
brother and in a tragic accident and I
was really kind of thinking about
skipping out on this whole Hollywood
thing for a while sorry to hear that
yeah I really just you know came out of
nowhere and shouldn't have happened and
from there I got this great gift you
know from from NIC pizzolatto an HBO
offered me this incredibly rich part in
true detective and the writing was just
so incredible and then to get to work
opposite my Herschel ollie for three
decades and grow old with him nicely
that was a dream you know that was a
that was a really incredible journey and
then after that I did a film and hasn't
come out yet that's I'm really proud of
too called embattled which is this kind
of family drama set against the backdrop
of UFC so it's pretty pretty gripping
film I think that'll probably be in the
summer
deputy before deputy I mean let's rest
on that one right there did you get into
the world of UFC I've got I've done some
mixed martial arts in films like I did a
film called foul
I worked with I worked with a lot of
Greg Jackson's team in New Mexico during
that filming and I'd met cowboy and a
lot of these big fighters Cerrone and
Keyshia our Dean and on the movie we had
cowboy was in there too but we had tyron
woodley we had Kenny Florian we had some
really great guys playing announcers and
involved I worked with a guy named Chris
Connelly who's out of Alabama who is a
great trainer and and learned a little
bit more I mean it was a it's a pretty
intense film I play kind of a fictitious
lightweight champion but kind of on his
way out kind of like a an American Conor
McGregor if if there was one Wow he's
he's a beast of a character and that
would be that very outspoken I'm just
trying to determine how much ass you
could kick whose ass could you kick
Stephen Dorff you know yeah you know I'm
more of a lover than a fighter rich but
in the mom he said I'm not a divider but
I'm just that's the way I were I roll
the same way too
I know you do that's my default I heard
about you yeah no I'm excited about that
fell I mean it's pretty heavy hitting it
was written by the guy that wrote
american history x and below David
McKenna he's a really talented writer
first time director okay and so we'll
see how that one goes and then I and
then I went right into deputy bill
Hollister and deputy right and that's
been kind of going for a while so which
deputy's a different show than true
detective is it it's a little more I
think popcorn it's a little more for for
the world you know it's it's not as nice
maybe of an audience it's it's really
made for America and why do you say that
Stephen Dorff here again deputy episode
2 of season 1 airs on Thursday night I
think sometime I think when you do
broadcast television which you know it's
just so big and it reaches so many more
people and I think you know you have
commercials yeah it's a different way of
working it's a different medium and in a
way but at the same time it's I love the
fact that it can reach so many people
and I like I like Bill Hollister cuz
he's kind of a no-nonsense kind of
antihero but he is a he is a good man
and he and he has great morals and he
throws himself in the in the middle of
harm's way every day
you know for for people that
he doesn't know and probably never will
know but that's his job and there's
something about law enforcement in
general that I have a huge respect for
you know whether it's firemen or
ESU workers in New York that I write
plate Scott Strauss in World Trade
Centers there's an incredible person and
I've got to know all these great guys
we're really the real heroes you know
what we do fact yeah that's a fact when
we when we do what we do we try to you
know give it as much right ride to give
it as much realism I try to talk to
these guys as much as I can right you
know we've working with a great guy Marc
Schlegel on this show who is a sergeant
in the LA Sheriff's Department and he's
just an incredible person you know he
can't be on set all the time with me but
he's there a lot and he's got a family
and a job to do which is putting away
bad guys so right but I've had an
incredible time getting to know these
guys and and try to do it some justice
you know again Thursdays at 9:00 Eastern
Time on Fox
how many tats do you have I got a lot
now that I've you know missing members
of my family so I've been kind of going
a little haywire I spent a little more
time in the makeup chair bill Hollister
doesn't have any tats it's a makeup a
makeup thing which is you know I hate
being in makeup but you know I had so
much practice some true detective like
five hours and makeup when we were all
yeah so this is not a bad thing no only
20 minutes we can cover them all so I
would probably answer your question I
don't know maybe 50 no 5-0 yeah just my
arms really that's it was the first one
you got first one I got was in Amsterdam
when I was 17 I guess sounds like I got
a Celtic Cross on the inside of my arm
that now looks more like a a faded low
not bad but it it was cool because at
this place hanky-panky in Amsterdam it's
odd that a place in Amsterdam would be
called hanky-panky yeah he gets a make
there were there any red lights in that
district there were some red lights in
that district and for me the Amsterdam
was like the 60s back then cuz you know
I wasn't here in the sixties so it was
kind of like just fun kinda it was kind
of cool
do you regret any ink that you have no I
never got one for like an ex-girlfriend
or had to change it to like
you know you know something else friends
have but I know most of my tats are
actually they mean a lot to me and the
family members I got my brother there I
got my dad my mom on your left arm
okay I got so many here I was born 19
cents a for my brother my brother was a
an amazing songwriter probably one of
the biggest in Nashville Andrew Dorothy
wrote all Blake Shelton's hits and so
songwriting kind of has followed in the
in the background of my family or and my
brother was really killing it in which
which makes me more sad that he couldn't
really be here through his succession or
still hearing his songs on the radio
every day so Paul Congrats on your
success sir thank you my new are very
welcome on that front
absolutely thanks ray everybody should
check out deputy on Fox it started
hearing episode one last week episode 2
is on Thursday night and good luck to
you come back anytime thanks rich I'd
love to come back yeah absolutely that's
Stephen Dorff right here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app